i'm the face of the seven not you
me i still score higher on every demo
that counts they
all love me
well congratulations
i mean this constant need to be loved by
everyone
is kind of pathetic but yay
okay welcome back everyone it's charlie
this is gonna be my video for the boys
season two episode four
everyone grab a glass of milk because
they took it to another level in this
episode
if you're new to the channel i'm doing
videos for all the episodes this season
be sure to subscribe to get everything
we'll do an amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
craziest moment from the episode on the
video
we'll do top 10 wtf and easter eggs as
we go along just careful for spoilers
from the boys season 2 episode 4 so
starting with number 10
they start with those funny jokes of the
video interviews that the deep is doing
with the church of the collective
interviewing different women to become
his wife quote unquote in an arranged
marriage that they claim will
rehabilitate his image and get him back
on the seven
i think we're all in agreement that of
course that's ridiculous and that's not
gonna get him back on the seven
the church is just trying to brainwash
him indoctrinate him like they try to
get other superheroes
this is a very clear parody of big
organizations like scientology or other
religions we're making all these jokes
about the fresca cult too
they didn't hammer home the fresca jokes
in this episode but i'd be willing to
bet that if you could look in the
background of most of the scenes
involving the church in this new church
character you'd probably see a can of
fresca somewhere
they have this montage of different
women that are kind of funny in their
own different ways each one has their
own sort of kink or weirdness or
weird backstory that they tell and as
funny as that super [ __ ] one was at
the end where he's like oh definitely
that one we want that one the one that
will do anything that i say
they just remind you how deeply he's let
the church sink its hooks into him
because they're like of course you get
to choose who you marry but no
you're gonna marry this girl right here
the funny thing about the one that they
chose for him to marry is that she's the
one that was all about that lover's pack
the ones that died together and were
found
fossilized so it almost sounds like
she's gonna try and have some sort of
death pact with the deep so somebody
warn him that's a bit of a red flag
number nine kimiko and frenchie's arc
takes a left turn when she drills down
on stormfront obsessed with getting
revenge
for the death of her brother who vote is
calling a supervillain they even blame
him for all the people the stormfront
killed in that building in the damage
that she caused
it's just another example of what they
did to butcher when homelander killed
stilwell
they control the media the television
stations the broadcasting the shows so
it's all part of their giant pr machine
spinning things the way they want to
spin them he's barely able to stop her
from throwing her life away like there's
no way that you're going to walk away
from this alive please
don't do it let's go home you're not
going to be able to beat her like this
there's a couple really cool stormfront
moments from the comic book that they
might wind up including in later
episodes so i don't want to talk about
those too much now in case they wind up
being spoilers
there's also that frenchie moment with
his other girlfriend where they talk
about
lamplighter foreshadowing something
later this season he's gonna be coming
onto the show
they actually kicked the character off
the seven right before the events of
season one episode one the premiere
that's when starlight joined the seven
replacing lamplighter so i'll talk more
about what's going on with lamplighter
when he actually shows up in an episode
which should be pretty soon
but number eight homelander in the shape
shifter still well this is probably one
of the funnier more wtf parts of the
episode
the reveal is kind of shocking too and
you don't really know what's going on
until the end of the episode
but for a brief second i actually
thought that he was hallucinating her
when we first met her because he is so
nuts it's not completely out of the
realm of possibilities
but it's just another superhero that has
shape-shifting abilities that he
probably pays to live out his fetish
fantasies with the replacement stillwell
i kind of wonder now if he was visiting
this person while stillwell was still
alive because
he didn't really consummate his
relationship with stilwell till right
before he wound up killing her
it's every bit as nuts as you would
expect him telling her
everything you think he wants to hear
you're amazing everything you do is
incredible
just being the mommy that he thinks that
he wants you're the most powerful person
on the planet
then obviously the real wtf twist is the
ending which we'll talk about in a
second because i think they're also
foreshadowing a major comic book twist
down the road number seven though
mother's milk huey and starlight's big
road trip
i really liked a lot of their casual
scenes together that didn't involve
a lot of action it was more about big
reveals and them just having fun
together learning about people's
backstories
singing a whole bunch of billy joel
while they traveled to learn the secret
of the superhero liberty from back
during the vietnam war era of the 70s
did this whole thing with starlight and
huey's relationship they're probably the
most wholesome couple
on the show there's still a couple
mostly just a couple that can't see each
other for now because of how serious
things are getting
you get a ton of mother's milk backstory
you learn his father was killed by
vaught because he tried to expose them
after something quote-unquote happened
to mother's milk
involving vot when he was a child i
think this is just meant to be a big
comic book easter egg for mother's milk
and his powers
i don't know if they're gonna do this on
the tv show but he does have powers in
the comics he has some
minor superpowers like enhanced strength
when he drinks
get it his mother's milk that's why his
name is mother's milk
he and homelander would definitely have
some stuff to talk about but tv show
mother's milk probably was just a test
subject of vaught and compound v
when he was a child and something went
sideways usually vaught only tests or
injects compound v into newborn babies
or really
really young kids but in some special
cases the effects are much greater when
they inject it during the fetus stages
of development
that's what they did with people like
homelander they injected massive amounts
of compound v into his mother's womb
when he was still a fetus developing
number six though starlight versus
homelander he gives her the business or
tries to give her the business in the
elevator after that little stillwell of
the fake
stillwell pep talk totally eats up all
her lies it seems like he's pretty
easily manipulated as his conversation
with stormfront proves later on
the showrunner said that this is because
homelanders real weakness is more
psychological than it is physical like
you might
not be able to hurt him physically very
easily but the right speech the right
phrases can completely [ __ ] him
emotionally
for now though she's still on the seven
she's still in the clear with homelander
which we cannot save for a train
so number five everyone press f in the
chat to pay respects to a train
homelander just gives him that funny
speech like we thank you for your
service buddy now get the hell out of
here don't let the door hit you in the
ass on the way out
there was some season 2 trailer footage
of him in that ohio dive bar
with the deep just drowning their
sorrows to make as many puns as possible
so maybe that's where he goes to seek
some solace like you also got kicked off
the seven i just got kicked off the
seven so let's hang out together
it'll be real funny to see how he reacts
to all the deep's weird cold stuff
if the deep tries to get him to also
join the church of the collective
number four though black noir and that
analysts were some of the mvps of the
episode the hijacks to track down
butcher they had some of the funniest
scenes
in the entire episode and it's all
because everyone's so terrified of black
noir
and because he doesn't speak it makes
him even scarier
just because you've seen the things that
he can do especially with that opening
scene from season 2 episode 1.
they were posting a bunch of pictures
from behind the scenes a while ago this
is what the actor
under the mask actually looks like but
after a case of red bull they find
butcher at becca's secret compound
and i think the reason why this is an
even bigger deal is because black noir
and the other members of the seven
don't know about becca and they don't
know about homelanders son
there was a moment during the season 2
trailer where we see some footage of
black noir
on a rooftop in a suburban looking house
so i'm hoping that this foreshadows
black noir
going to becca's house to investigate
homelander's son in the sun
using his powers to try and stop black
noir we've already seen that he can soak
a ton of energy damage because that
opening scene
and during this episode in particular
butcher and other people
keep referencing the kids glowing eyes
and heat vision so i'm just hoping that
they have a scene where he unleashes his
heat vision on black noir for the very
first time just frying him a little
even giving him a full blast wouldn't be
enough to kill him as we've seen it
seems like he regenerates pretty fast
number three though butcher finds his
wife finally and somehow it's not even
the biggest twist
of the episode but they answer a bunch
of long-running questions about what
really happened to her back then
she says she did not go willingly with a
capital r when referencing what happened
with homelander son where that came from
she hates being trapped in vat's
compound but the kid seems like he might
turn out alright with her influence and
she doesn't want to abandon him to
vaught
so that they can just turn him into
another psychopath like homelander
becca also kind of says something that
foreshadows the stormfront reveal at the
end of the episode too
she says there'd be two [ __ ] out
there then
which we know is actually true because
now we know stormfront's secret
there are now two of them that we know
about that are out there two really
terrible villains
becca also seems like she does want to
be with butcher but she understands his
dark side and how crazy he
gets but she needs to stay at the
compound to protect the superboy
not because she doesn't want to be with
butcher they did proceed to get it on
pretty quickly though and she will be in
more of the episodes this season so they
will be following up on what's going on
with her
in the sun here like the black noir
foreshadowing that i mentioned
number two stormfront versus homelander
and her big
secret so i think the chemistry between
the two of them is great it's fun to
watch her talk circles around him and
manipulate
him you could see the confusion on his
face like he thinks this is all about
her wanting to take control of the seven
but she really doesn't care about any of
that
to her credit she does try to explain
the four-dimensional chess game that
she's playing with the media and all
these people in the public
i'm paying these bloggers with coupons
and you had to spend 270 million dollars
the look of confusion on his face is
hilarious like she stops him dead in his
tracks and you can see the hamster just
jump off the wheel in his head like wait
what
just happened here what's going on what
are you talking about he's clearly
affected by her verbal takedown too
you're pathetic for needing people's
approval so desperately which they then
pay off at the end of the episode
but obviously the even bigger reveal is
that stormfront is actually just
liberty from the 1970s and she just
changed her identity
and hasn't aged in the last 48 years so
that would put her around the vietnam
era war when this flashback scene is
happening
the really big stormfront comic book
easter egg here too is actually for
the original version of the character in
the comics he actually was created by
german scientists
during world war ii mother's milk says
that she's around 78 years old in
present day that would mean that she was
born
in 1942 smack dab in the middle of world
war
ii in the comics they do the exact same
thing with the character 2
in present day vaught creates a new
identity stormfront for this
quote-unquote
hero and says that they're a viking
because it's a big thor
marvel avengers easter egg he leads a
team called payback which is another
avengers reference
the difference with the tv show version
of the character is that after
vaught came to the united states through
operation paperclip
after world war ii and he started
experimenting on people it sounds like
they found stormfront
as a baby experimented on compound v
with her turned her into the liberty
character
and once she reached maturity she just
stopped aging she's just been this age
for the last 48 years but number one
though probably the biggest wtf moment
of the episode
has to be homelander almost one doing it
with himself
and then two killing himself the way
they played this was not subtle at all
it was like he was living out a
domination fantasy of sorts
with himself like he was telling himself
off you're weak you're nothing
then stormfront's earworm does its evil
magic on him in his brain and he comes
to the realization that i don't need
anyone to love me i don't need anyone's
approval
which kind of implies that he's going to
become an even worse villain now because
what happens when a psycho like him
doesn't care about the approval of other
people that's a real super villain in
the making there so it just sounds like
things are going to completely spiral
out of control in the best
possible way i can't wait to see it all
go down the drain for them
i don't want to talk too much about what
happens in the future of the comics in
case the show winds up doing it
but this does imply that they might be
going for a big
wtf twist most of you who have read the
comic probably know what i'm talking
about
please don't post those spoilers in the
comments below
everyone let me know in the comments
what your favorite moment of the episode
was and if you spotted any big easter
eggs in the episode that i didn't
mention in the video just write them
below in the comments
my episode 5 video will post next friday
while you wait for everything click here
for the boys season 2
short movie all about butcher and click
here for the boys season 2 episode 1
through 3 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]